hello
and thank you for joining us for today's
presentation
part of our agilent cell analysis global
conference
my name is yama abbasi i'm the head of
business and application development
within cell analysis division
before i introduce our speakers for
today allow me to share a bit about
agilent and our products for cell
analysis
agilent is a trusted leader in life
sciences clinical research diagnostics
and applied chemical markets providing
laboratories with instruments services
consumables applications
and expertise to enable our customers to
gain the insights they seek
aca is one of the newest addition to
agilent cell analysis division
which includes seahorse luxel
and also biotech which was recently
acquired by
agilent
agilent's rapidly growing cell analysis
portfolio
enables deeper more reliable insight
across a variety of cell analysis
applications
where investigators and drug developers
seek to understand
complex cellular environments and
interactions
including sulfate fitness and function
our comprehensive cell analysis tools
are critically important in various
investigative fields such as cancer
inflammation immunology immune oncology
and as you'll find out today virology
in this session we have the privilege of
having two
excellent speakers from la bio in con
france first i am delighted to introduce
dr stefan pernast
began his research career in 1990 at the
university of khan
in france within the laboratory of
biochemistry of connective tissue
developing molecular tools for cytokine
expression studies in humans
he joined the frank doncom
laboratory in france with the mission of
building up
an r d service in 1995.
after having set up a pcr assays in
different animal species he focused on
equine viral diseases
and more recently on herpes
herpes virus equine arthritis equine
influenza
and a passivirus his recent
research focuses on ehv-1
and the different expression forms of
its pathology
specifically ehv-1 associated
milo myeloencephalopathy his team has
developed different study models for
equine herpes viruses which have led
recently to the isolation of new strains
of ehv1
and the implementation of a screening
protocol
for anti-viral molecules based on the
real-time cell analysis technology
since 2018 he manages
the impedance cell platform in a bsl2
confinement as well dr pernaz gets
involved in numerous training sessions
in molecular biology
since 1993 at the university of khan
and is furthermore an expert of the
afner
group which is the french agency for
standardization
for pcr methods and animal health he has
also been an auditor for the french
accreditation
committee kofrak in molecular biology
and animal health since 2014.
our second speaker is kome
thiolent who obtained his master's
degree in science
in 2016 from the university of khan
in normandy he worked for a year
at the frank doncamp laboratory as an
engineer and started working with the
real-time cell analysis technology
since 2007 where comey has been a
doctoral student at the university at
the university of khan and he continues
to work at the frank.com
laboratory he's currently in the last
year of
his doctor doctorate studies he uses the
excellence technology throughout his
doctoral work to ident
identify new antiviral compounds
to fight equine herpes virus
as part of his training um comey also
went to
dr hand's new new neck laboratory at the
university of
ghent in belgium in order to develop
innovative cell models for the study of
ehv1
he has enjoyed living in each of these
great cities getting to know people from
diverse parts of the us
as as well as all over the world before
we
start and i pass pass it on to dr pernaz
i just want to mention a couple of
housekeeping notes
there will be a question and answer
period immediately
following the talk and to help us get as
many of your questions as possible we
encourage you to type in your questions
during the
presentation and with that i will hand
over
to dr pronounced and followed by comey
thank you yama for the introduction it's
a real pleasure to see you again in 2020
hello everyone and before starting the
presentation
i would like to thank everyone in
organizing
involved in organizing this webinar ema
pascal yama and the project from agilent
today's talk to concern the
identification of antiviral compounds
against equinox wireless one using
real-time cellular ss spinning
i will give you a brief introduction to
our technological platform
which is an open platform for research
programs
or services with industry
and then gabrielle sutton and chrome
taylor
two doctoral students from the
university of chrome
[Music]
working in our laboratory will present
recent data
to you obtained with this technology
against
hv-1 a virus responsible for significant
economic losses for the equine industry
labio our laboratory is a laboratory
involved in diagnosis and research in
three different
areas animal health with a specific
focus
on disease of a horse food
and environment we are located in france
and more precisely in normandy
one of the most famous regions of all
the breeders in the world
and we are not so far from monster
michelle
and we are working on a research
platform called
normandy18 valley dedicated to equine
health
and the name of this real-time cell
analysis facility
is impedance cell and all research
involving pathogens viruses bacteria
is carried out in this platform which
hosts
level 2 and level 3 facilities
impedance cells our platform for
measuring cell activity in real time
has the particularity of being in
located on two different
sites in the city of chrome the historic
site is located in a concert research
institute
at the franco barclays center and our
colleagues
had a very good grasp of the technology
but when we started the collaboration we
quickly
identified a major problem
it was not possible for our credits to
welcome us in the laboratory
because we work with viruses this is why
we have the ddc this is why we have
decided to equip
a second site dedicated to pathogens
and together on bistro sites with our
panel of
equipment we now offer scientific
collaboration
and services as well as teaching
and training for students
indeed with expertise acquired for 8 to
10 years now
we propose to support researchers in
many different fields as you
can see on this slide and even if our
major developments are in the field of
oncology and biology
when started we are starting to work on
bacteriology
and a new immunological methodology with
airtessia technology but
today we will focus on virology
and now gabrielle and chrome will start
the scientific discussion with a
presentation of the ehv1 virus
and explain how this technology
has helped us to find new compounds to
fight
against airbase virus in equilibrium
[Music]
hello i'm gabriel satin and i'll just
make a short introduction on where you
could have this
buy this one
[Music]
i'll start with a bit of taxing on me
and just show you where
um each human is located in the big
carcass
uh byrody family so it's part of the
alpha herpes varying sub family and part
of the gender
very similar virus in this group
just to give you an idea we can also
find the virus that causes
chickenpox so each other one is in this
group alongside with php 3
4 8 and 9 3 1
3 and 4 in thick mostly uh
horses uh each v8 is quite known
to infect donkeys but it also infects
horses and the hv-1 eat9 sorry
inflicts liquid and non-increase quite
there's been some
cases in wild animals
there are three other ehvs they're part
of the gamma herpes varnish
superfamily which are hb25 and hb7
[Music]
i'll keep going with some general
information um
the hp one is a double stranded dna
virus it is
endemic to the world horse population
with the exception of the
ice lending force uh indeed uh agent one
was never brought to iceland uh
it is a country that is free from the
virus which is not the case for
uh with each report each v1 is the most
prevalent viral pathogen victim horses
when it when it infects horses it
generally
does not cause any clinical signs but in
some case
cases according to the age of the horses
their general general condition to their
immune status
it can cause three types of disease
the first one is the respiratory disease
as the first site of the infection is
the respiratory
traxis in this case the
horses will cuff they will have fever
and shown
nasal discharge at this stage
either the horses will manage to fight
and to
stop the viral infection and recover
or the virus will manage to reach and
infect
the blood cells and then disseminate in
the
body uh in this case they will
gain some they will reach reach some
organs that can be the uterus in the
case
of mares and in the case of pregnant
males it will cause abortion
or a stillborn death there's been some
cases of
falls that were born sick and died in a
few hours or days
afterwards but also some cases of horses
that
were worn sick and recovered these
horses generally have quite
um big
respiratory issues and for quite a long
time
when it disseminate in the body the
virus can also reach the
central nervous system and cause neural
neurological signs these signs can be
can go from ataxia to complete paralysis
and in some cases they require
uh euthanasia especially when the horse
has been laying down
quite a long time
[Music]
when the virus
inflate the blood cells and reach other
organs
uh it is called what we call
cell-associated virulence
in fact it is the fact that the the
virus will infect
the blood vessels around the organ
i've just cited before so the truth of
the central nervous
system and this is the infection of
these
blood vessels that will cause the
clinical signs
[Music]
so what is the impact of the eg1 on the
equine world so as
we just saw the clinical signs are quite
important
especially in the case of abortion and
in neurological disease there's been
some report of abortion stones
which are quite impressive and in france
and also uh the issue of
the neurological disease is quite often
dramatic
there's another impact on the implant
world is
an in an economic impact as we all know
the fine industry
is quite an important industry due to
their uh
races and also the sales so
um the disease have uh questioned impact
on this part
of the industry
[Music]
i'll keep going with just a short slide
to give you an idea of the virus
structure which is a typical structure
of the the herpes viruses in general
so um in the case of eg1
it has
double-stranded dna of 150 kilobase
which is wrapped around protein and
forming the core the core is
is surrounded by a capsid
which is surrounded by the tiguan
containing some
chicken proteins this protein will be
very important in the viral cycle
all this core plus
capsid prestigement is an envelope in a
lipid bilayer which contains on its
surface
12 glycoproteins these glycoproteins
will be very important for the virus to
get into the cells
and then to carry out
its viral cycle
[Music]
in terms of virus culture of in vitro
virus culture uh in our lab we are used
to
grow the virus on three cell lines
which are the rapid kidney cells the
equine dermal cells
and also the equine embryonic human
cells
so it again say see um
the the cytoplastic effects on the three
cell lines
are quite different uh but they are very
recognizable
easy to differenti differentiate from
the non-infected cells these three
models have been
uh used on the intelligence technology
and equipment
and more about it later on
[Music]
i'll keep going with a bit of
information on the genetic
investigation they have been carried out
uh
over the last decades
[Music]
the big uh the big discovery happened in
2006 uh when
a team just made a correlation between a
mutation on the dna polymerase gene
which is the old city uh
so uh the creation between the mutation
on this gene
in position 2254 and the
neuropathogenicity of the strains
so what they discovered was that uh
according to the data they managed to
collect
uh most of the strains that were
carrying a granules
in position 2254 uh were associated with
neurological psychical science
while most of the strain that carried um
[Music]
an adenine in this position uh were not
associated with neurological signs
so from this work
um strains were generally uh
either neuropathogenic or non-muscle
pathogen according to
the genotype in physician 2254.
um after this work there's been some
more work so
many teams try to create data too and
try to to find this correlation
and uh which was um what happened is
that this correlation was not exclusive
it wasn't always
that clear anyway there there's been a
lot of concerns
uh about this uh mutation
there's also been some theogenic
analysis based on
uh specific genes so mostly of 13
or 68. and there's also been some
philogenic analysis that uh took into
consideration
bigger parts of the genome so either
mental
locus sequence typing which uh consists
in
sequences just bits of
the genome but in order to cover uh
the genome the complete genome or a
whole genome sequencing
the mlst is a much
faster and less expensive way of
of having an information that
that is quite close to your whole genome
sequencing
the reason i'm telling you about um
genetic investigation and
more precisely about the mutation
physician 254
is that we isolated in 2018
in our lab has trained uh that we wanted
to type for
the mutation in position 2254
and it happened that we couldn't type it
this happens
quite often but in this case uh we had
uh multiple samples from the same
outbreak
and none of them could be typed for
either a or g
so we couldn't say if it was in the
neuropathy genetic or
non-neuroglycogenic type
uh this outbreak involved neurological
clinical signs
so we did a little sequencing to see
what was happening what was uh
where was the big mystery on this
sequence and we found that there was
acetosine
on this um position 2254.
so this had never been described before
and
this uh nucleotide change also
implied an amino acid change as it was
the case
for a ang but a different one
so uh we had this train we didn't
know anything about this new mutation so
all we
had to do was to start and explore
and this is where uh the exiligence
technology helped us
uh as we first started to see how the
virus grew
on cells so um as you can see on the
graph
we tried to see um to infect
pek cells so equine and
cells with um the new isolated strength
which is the one you just wrote in red
and also with strands that we were used
to work on which are
the a g and 2g strains you can see on
the graph
in the first thing we could see was that
in terms of um
of uh growth on the on the sales
um the behavior was quite
like the other streams this is what this
was the first information
which was quite interesting we also
performed some antiviral investigation
on this stream to see and compared it to
other strengths that we and this is a
part
[ __ ] we'll present you and i'll let him
go into the details
thank you very much for your attention
bye
[Music]
wow
[Music]
okay good morning everyone i'm kumchan
and i'm phd student at the university of
corn normandy and atlabel
and stephan pronounced is my supervisor
and today i'm going to present you my
phd work
and more specifically why and how we use
the accident technology
i'm a vibrologist and i work on equine
hepatology
one of the nine hepatoviruses known to
infect bounces
to fight this virus vaccines are
available
they have a good efficacy to reduce the
virus dissemination
and respiratory disease however they
are not fully effective against abortion
and they
have no effect on nervous disease in
addition the coverage remains
insufficient
in view of this limitation the
veterinary operations have turned
towards alternative traits
and the use of antibiotic therapy
shows a great interest however the
therapeutic arsenal
again has an equine app analysis
is very limited and no molecules have a
marketing authorization
in marketing equine species despite
a critical need that is why it's
important to develop
new components or test available
components with possible
effects against equine applications and
our approach is to develop an effective
tool for the screening of chemical
coupons
against equine apes viruses
however at the beginning of my thesis we
are fast
faced to one problem indeed at 48 hour
post infection
when we are the total sympathetic effect
induced by 31 characterized by
surrounding and detachment
on equine thermal cells no cell
visibility loss was detected by triple
blue stain
and by atp measurement in addition
we have shown that cells do not activate
apoptosis at this time and this result
was confirmed by two household studies
in view of the inefficiency of classical
assay
we have considered the use of more
original technology
based on impedance measurement
this technology is the incident system
and for this purpose we are first
monitoring in one
time the eh1 infectivity of equine
thermal cells by
impedance measurement and microscope as
you can see on this slide
this graph represents the impedance
measurement as a function of time
the red curve reflects the impedance of
non-infected cells
and the pinker the impedance of the edge
one infected cells
the decrease of the pinker is correlated
with psitopathopathogenic effect
formation induced by heatwave
as you can see on this move and
at 48 hour percent friction when the
cell index reached a new value
we have a total sympathetic effect
as excellent system is not specific we
have measured the erg1
copy genome number in the cell culture
supernatural
and as you can see erg-1 genome copy
number
encrypts significantly in line with
varus mediated systematic effect
formation
and inversely with the cell addicts
decreasing
this result confirms the ability of its
electrons system for monitoring a
phosphorous
infection of all equine thermal cells
following this result we have studied
the capacity of this technology to
monitor the effect
of the two main possible compounds used
against gluman
apostleruses asecouria and burns
and i'll present you the granscovir
result on this slide
on this graph we have a red and pink
control
and the green shed curve reflects the
impedance measurement of
infected cells and treated with
increased concentration of gland secret
and results show that high concentration
of ganciclovir presents the cell and it
decreases
induced by hd1 infection and lower
concentration
were less effective these results were
confirmed by viral load computation
at 48 hour post infection and by
microscopic affair observation
this result showed that its agent system
is
effective to evaluate the antiviral
effect of chemical compounds
and similar results were obtained with
ac trigger training
the same experiments were made on eav4
and esv3 on equine thermal cells
and similar results to eag-1 were
obtained for executive and gun
supervision
following this result we have developed
an algorithm for use execution system
for the screening
of three three thousand compounds
against sierra
and now let me present you the flow
share of plate analysis
first we calculate the z prime factor
based on the array and of curve data
this value
is an useful tool to determine the
quality of screen
and in our experiment the z factor value
was from
above open forum for edge plate which
convalidate
and prove the high throughputness of our
ac
then we analyze the curve profile
on the area under curve value and we
have two specific
one one compounds with non-effective
a non-representative curve and
comparable
area under curve value with untreated
control were not considered
as potential intervals against eight
whereas compounds with a strong
difference of area under curve
with control were considered as
potential integral compounds
for them we calculate the terror queue
per kill to the set
to the cylinder to decrease by 50
percent after various infection
called c850 and against we have two
specific cases
one component with a c8050 comparable
with virus only
was removing as potential antibiotic
components
but couple with a strong increase
of c850 of coupons where the c8050
is not is not calculable were confirmed
as potential onstable compounds against
eag-1
in our experiment where we have
screening a
screen approximately 3 000 coupons we
have found
21 compounds with a positive score
and among that compounds we found
acyclovir and galaxy bubble
which proved the high throughputness of
our screen
the antiviral effect of this compound
was then confirmed by those reports sc
measurement
by viral load quantitation and impedance
measurement
and results are presented in this table
the important point here is that we have
compared the
half maximum effective concentration of
these compounds
obtained by qpsr and rccr and
we observe a good correlation between
this value
with a l-square of 0.85
and this result demonstrates the
pertinence to use execution system
to offer interval research
among the 21 feet height were selected
because they can keep
the half maximum effective concentration
below
50 micromolar as a function of time
and do not shoot any toxicity at 80
micromolar the antiviral effect of this
compound
was then evaluated on three different
cell models using
excellent system the equandermal cell
the equine embryonic lung cells
and the rabbit kidney cells harmonious
compound biocyclovia did not show
any antiviral effect on rabbit kidney
cells
on unequaled embryonic kidney cells and
was
and was removed of the list
of selective compounds clovir was the
least effective on the three cells
models
and was at the remove of the list of the
selective components
these compounds were also testing
against three different strain of eg1
using intelligent system
and no difference of susceptibility was
observed between this trend
actually we have realized a communism
study using its agent system
to find potential certain synergical
effect
in order to reduce the cost of the
treatment and the potential toxicity of
this compound
we have first realized a communism
analysis based on the max energy
calculation analysis system for this we
have used the array under curved data
and the results are presented in this
table
and among the four communism tested here
only the communism of valuencyclovir
show a synergical effect characterized
by the blue pipe of the in the figure
one
in the figure hey
and all other communism show additive
health
then the combination of valencia virtus
decisively
was then evaluated using iso program
analysis
using the half maximal effective
concentration
obtained by excellent system and result
was presented in the figure b
hash as shown on this figure all points
obtained
were under the red additive line
which confirms the surgical effect of
this combination finally this
combination what test
was tested using the shuttle ali method
with
qpcr and against results show synergies
so we can say that this communism
study demonstrated the good synergies
between valganciclovia and the system
vagrancy coveria is a one law antiviral
component again numerous helpers viruses
and this mode of action is well known
however
the sea database was never described
effective against dna varies
before so we have begun to study the
mode of action of this comp
to evaluate whether the setup in
integration
in target cell dnr provides proof
protection fraud
from each one infection cells were
treated overnight with deceitability
before infection
on or just after infection
and both results obtained by qpsl and
rtcs
show that this system in pre-treatment
did not protect
cells from cpa formation and virus
replication and only
a post-infection treatment with dc type
was working to observe some significant
inhibition of eag-1 replication
secondly as decitabine is known
to induce cellular dna hypomethylation
we have tested the effect of rg108
a well-known dna methyltransferable
methyltransferase inhibitor
and this compound did not show any
optimal effect
at the concentration for which
deceitability is effective
this suggests that notable effect of
this stability
is not mediated by cellular dna
hypomethylation
finally decetabine is a deoxidine analog
and we have tested the effect of
nucleotide
on the decitabin antiviral effect and
of all testing nucleosis only
dioxitidine
blocks the antiviral activity of
dicetabine in
a dose-dependent manner this result
suggests
that decitabine arc in competition with
deoxytidine
to be phosphorylated by deoxitizing
kinase and
is incorporated into cellular and viral
dna
to conclude the k point i'd like you to
remember
are one the oxygen system is well
adapted to study the equine hepath
versus
infection on different cells model
secondly the incident
system is adapted for the screening of
antibiotics against ert1
then we have identified 21 coupon
effective years
against eng-1 but only eight were
identified very
strongly effective against eig one and
the combination of
palgoncyclovir plasticitabin show a good
synaptical
effect
[Music]
so finally all the data presented during
this presentation have been
recently published in various sciences
journals
as you can see on this slide
thank you for your attention and if you
are any question
we will be happy to answer
okay well thank you very much thank you
for that
excellent uh presentation dr panas
and also uh comey and gabrielle
appreciate it thank you um and so
there's
certainly some some questions here that
uh that
that came up and i would like to just
take a moment
and then ask those questions please feel
free
to to to to answer
to answer those as you like so one of
one of the
the first questions that i received was
whether
um if there is any neutralizing
antibody development against equine
herpes virus if any of
that kind of work is going on
uh yes uh there is um
uh there's the reference methodology
that is used for a diagonal stitch
and that titus neutral
neutral using antibodies against uh
ehv one the only problem with this um
tested that there are some crossing
antibodies with ch before so
um gives an idea of
of the the tai cha but um there is this
cross we actually perform and we are
also working on
uh neutralizing antibody um
uh the development on the opera method
uh that could be performed on the uh
intelligence uh technology but this is
uh
uh still in progress uh and uh
we're not able to uh to present a cheat
and
still need to be uh to be uh
improved well we we certainly look
forward to
uh an update on that work at the
appropriate time
thank you um so one of one of the
the figures that really was striking
was the fact that uh you showed um
that this equine herpes virus it doesn't
actually cause cytotoxicity per se
as in cell death but but
because because you couldn't detect it
by caspase and
then also some viability viability dies
but you were able to see it by
accelerant system
so uh so you so this is more of a
massive morphological change is that is
that correct
yes it's uh it's correct we use this
technology because this plg one caused
a strong morphological change
and
[Music]
models so yes this technology is very
useful for our couple
of cell and viruses
great and and you uh also mentioned
uh three different cell types that you
were using on three different cell
models
that you were using and and this uh
cytopathic effect
is similar in all three cell types
um no the systomatic effect on
effect are not similar but we also
observe a cell detachment and
for the two other cells model used in
this presentation
we observe a cell destruction induced by
chd1
only equanda marcel were not this
destroyed by lg-1
okay thank you
so in terms of the
vaccine um what is what is
the major immunogenic component of the
virus
uh which which is there which which
protein on the surface is the major
immunogenic component
okay thank you jana for a question and
concerning vaccine
the most important part is the
glycoprotein
involved in the attachment and all over
introduction of a virus in sales like gb
gd but as prom said
the vaccine has efficacity and is very
important for us
in history but actually as there is no
protection against neurological forms
it's very important to develop a
complementary
methodology with this new approach with
antiviral troops
great thank you very much thank you
even though i know you did not
specifically
mention it but do you believe that the
accelerant
system could also be used to test
um basically the the serum of the horse
after
vaccination to uh check for
uh neutralization do you think it could
also be used for those types of studies
as well
i just started to answer and ask
gabrielle to complete but as she said
before it's something something ongoing
in our lab
is to develop the technology to measure
the quantity of antibodies with a good
computation
in serum as you say and actually we have
some
preliminary results very
interesting but as you say i think we
need to have a
new meeting to discuss but if you really
want to say more
yeah the the objective of the
development
is the same as for the classical method
is just to be able as you said
to uh to see a change of build
of nerve antibody tiger after this has
been
vaccinated or inflicted uh unfortunately
there will no
uh there'll be no way to know if uh this
uh change of title is due to vaccination
or infection
uh this is not a virus
is not uh well appropriate for this but
it will at least be
a good way to know uh the union status
of the goods um at
a specific time and if i can
complete i just want to mention that
that we have
zero neutralization methods uh we have
the oie methods and also we have a
complementation essay but we are very
interesting to test this new approach
with the intelligence system to obtain a
good
frantification of antibodies
so it's something very interesting
fantastic thank you thank you very much
thank you
so uh gabrielle you you
showed some data about different genetic
variants of the virus and and and
basically you could say that you were
looking at viral fitness
in some way in terms of uh cytopathic
effect or infectivity
but but you demonstrated you showed that
there was not
a major difference amongst the different
genetic variants in terms of the
infectivity
is that correct yes uh this was just a
real
uh first uh first look with this um
we didn't go further and knowing what
was happening exactly during the the
environmental cycle of the virus but
just a first look um the virus that had
this big change in that
in the mutation that has been uh uh
very discussed during the last decades
uh concerning neuropathogenicity this
mutation did not uh prevent the virus
from
going to the exact same cells as you can
see there
[Music]
the cells responded exactly the same way
in terms of timing on the extensions so
although we can't conclude anything on
the strange behavior
uh in terms of uh mechanistic and
uh and everything we can at least have a
first look saying
we know that it can get into the cells
the same way as
the the other strange we are
very sure it is the first step i would
say
okay great thank you
so let's uh get to the there's some
questions about the screening
part here so very nice very exciting
data about the screening so
3000 compound screening and
then managed to uh get some
really nice hits so uh first and
foremost
are any of these compounds currently
being evaluated in any
trials uh uh as we speak
okay so we perform uh
just before the lockdown in france an
interesting study with
our colleagues from the inner
institution
and we look for the activity of
a valency level which is one of the
most described anterior molecules in the
new one also
and actually the results are not
we have the razors but the paper is in
preparation
so i can just say that we have effects
we don't avoid the disease but we have
very interesting effects
it's only actually in vivo
in vivo evaluation and we are on going
for
to see more
very exciting yeah we definitely look
forward to
uh seeing the results of this uh this
study hopefully sometime
sometime sometime soon so uh
comey i i really liked your
analysis analysis methods in terms of
looking at screening for these compounds
so you mentioned that
you used area under the curve
as a way to evaluate the activity
of the compounds i'm just curious
whether you had also looked at other
parameters
to analyze the excel agents the
excellence curves for example
did you try any of the slope so looking
at the slope
uh or maybe even looking at the
cytopathic effect at a given time
and how did those analysis
compare to area under the curve
uh yes for the animalization we use
[Music]
excel and
we don't use the slope for the
analyzation but we have
we have tried different way of
analyzation
and we for us the good cop
the good analyzation is the couple of
the area under curve
and the c8050 value
because one of the
if we take only the array under curve
we have a lot of mistake and it's the
same
if we use only the c8050 value
so when we use the
both of them and we
look at the curve profile after we have
we we observe a good
we observe that this combination is very
good
for this screening but we have
used different parameters but this
parameter
need to be adapted from the cells
and the virus tested
okay clear yes yes
absolutely absolutely thank you yeah
thank you for that
um
so you also mentioned some studies about
uh basically mechanism looking at the
mechanism of
action of of of the compound
and then especially with this the
cetapine
and and uh so just to be clear was the
centipede
one of the compounds that you identify
through your actual screening method
yes yes okay one of the components
intensified during
our screening and it's one of the
compounds
never described before again effective
again
dna virus i said i said this
is very interesting okay
fantastic so i'm assuming that there's
going to be some follow-up work
to hopefully some publication coming out
that would describe
describe this a bit a bit further yeah
thank you okay great
um okay it seems that uh
those are the extent of the questions
that we have had
so uh this uh this was a really really
exciting
uh presentation you know thank you
so much for uh sharing this with with uh
with us
and in our audience it's clear that uh
you know the accelergence system
real-time cell analysis you've
definitely put it into good use
for this novel uh novel way of basically
coming up with antiviral compounds
you've used it
basically for looking at viral fitness
you've used it for screening purposes
you are now
also using it for neutralizing antibody
characterization
and then also mechanism of action so
many different ways that the technology
can be
can be utilized thank you
okay well we appreciate your
participation
thank you very much and we look forward
to
another presentation at a future date to
get a follow-up in this exciting work
thank you thank you appreciate it thank
you very much
bye